no tropical Cyclone Freddy has Unleashed
powerful winds heavy rain and floods in
Mozambique for the second time at least
28 people have been killed and tens of
thousands of homes have been damaged
Freddie is the southern hemisphere's
longest lasting tropical Cyclone on
record it started 35 days ago in the
Western Pacific and has traveled more
than 8 000 kilometers gathering strength
over the Indian Ocean
it made landfall on Madagascar as a
tropical Cyclone moved on to batter
Mozambique now it could gained strength
over the Indian Ocean
um has hit Mozambique once again as it
Bears down on the southern tip of
neighboring Malawi now Mozambique has
seen more than a Year's worth of rain in
the past four weeks the UN says more
than half a million people could face a
humanitarian crisis in one of the
world's poorest Nations many people have
been urged to move to temporary shelters
to protect my house with sandbags and
tarps so I don't have aggravating
situations the storm is just starting
you don't know what will happen in about
two hours
the situation is really chaotic lots of
Destruction cutting down of trees also
Fallen houses so I have to find ways to
cover them with zinc sheets or even find
a way to try to survive
is the country director for for Africa
Mozambique it's one of the aid groups
that's on the ground and he joins us now
live from maputo good to have you with
us on the program can you just bring us
up to speed on the situation where you
are in the situation that you're facing
thank you uh the situation is really
dramatic as the second one is coming for
the second time and is just affected the
Zambezi Province
yesterday from 18 hours to 20 hours
yesterday
some areas where the Cyclone made
landfall have been placed into lockdown
so what sorts of numbers are affected by
this and what are the people that are in
those lockdown areas telling you
uh the issue we're very limited
information currently uh regards to the
the second one uh how you know the
information on the extent of the
flooding is so far is no connection for
with electricity in internet in zambezia
currently so we we have no much
information but we're working in
coordination with National Institute for
disaster risk management and reduction
to get more information to see how can
one can we assist the communities that
elevate the suffering of course with
communication uh difficult excess rain
and flooding can lead to diseases and
ailments like diarrhea and cholera and
they can become a very big issue how
concerned are you about this and how are
you preparing for it
yeah of course whenever uh the floods
occur and you know this situation on on
Cyclone normally it's it's it's very
obviously that the color outbreak you
know
appears in the of course we with our
team we are we are we are on the ground
and working alongside the community
trying to assist as much as we can
assisting with the food shelter and
blankets so
basically that's what we're trying to do
and see whenever we have the statistics
on on on the situation on the ground
we'll be able to uh provide more so if
you want to get involved please visit
for africa.org and delayed well we
should see uh what happens certainly and
keep in touch with you as that situation
develops I'll send you a mukavela for
Africa Mozambique country director
thanks for joining us
thank you